(617) 830-4750.
Let's go next to our caller from the three,
four, seven area code.
Who's calling today from three four seven?
Yeah.
Hello?
Yeah, that's you.
Oh, uh, one second.
Let me get off speaker please.
All right.
Hi, this is Chi from Philadelphia.
Very good.
So yeah.
Um, so I've been thinking about like the rise
of anti intellectual a man like anti-vaxxer
than the Americans that don't believe that
climate change was a real issue.
Yeah.
That was wondering how you actually get through
to those people because it's really an elective,
biggest issue that's kind of we're going to
be facing in the next few decades.
Yeah, it's an open question.
I mean I think what we don't do is just like
throw facts at people even though we imagine,
hey, if, if I just got facts that didn't come
inside with what I think, I would just change
my opinion.
Maybe some of us would.
But for most people that doesn't really work.
What we've heard in our interviews with people
who have done documentaries and, and studied
at some of these anti-science movements, uh,
works best is sort of empathic listening to
their perspective and, and sort of a respectful
probing about what would change their mind.
How did they come to the conclusions and sort
of encouraging them to find contradictory
evidence on their own rather than sort of
like pummeling them over the head with it.
But it's really difficult.
And from, you know, I've said before, like
for winning elections, trying to change people's
minds isn't a good strategy.
You're not going to be able to change Trumpists
minds nearly as easily as you can.
Just find progressive's who don't like Trump
and convincing them to just go and vote.
But you're right that when it comes to society,
the antivirus stuff has a real impact.
Right?
Like we need to figure out a strategy because
we've got more measles cases than we've had
in 30 years or whatever and I don't know what
the answer is.
Yeah,
right.
And I feel like, I mean climate change is
going to be our biggest challenge in the next
12 years.
Yeah.
I was thinking, and I know this would be a
weird strategy to like convince lack of white
nationalist kind of people with that climate
change have an issue with that.
There's going to be a huge migration crisis
once, like a lot of the big issue with here.
I'm not sure if that would,
that is.
So I've been trying, so I've been, I bet there's
an open debate about whether to appeal to
your political opposition on their values
rather than yours is effective.
But there are two things that are potentially
interesting when trying to talk to the right
about climate change.
One is if you're a pro business right winger,
it's really hard for businesses to do well
if they're underwater.
It's really hard for businesses to do well
if you have, uh, people who are having to
migrate inland because coastal cities are
underwater and you're making sort of sort
of the exact same point with your idea.
And um, I don't know if that would be effective.
I mean, if you're coming, if you're truly
a climate change denier in that you simply
don't think any of this stuff is going to
happen.
You probably just ignore it and say, sure,
the migration crisis would be bad, but it's
not going to happen because climate change
is fake.
Yeah.
Yup.
Absolutely.
Kai, thank you, Kai from Billy.
Great to hear from you.
Appreciate the phone call.